bah alors on a passé la semaine à
chercher l'amour sur teen d'heure et du
coup on a loupé toute l'actu people
pas de panique on vous résume tout et on
commence avec aya nakamura qui n'en
finit pas d'être vexé il faut dire qu'on
sait que la chanteuse aux trois cent
mille albums vendus est un peu
susceptibles quand il s'agit de son nom
d'artiste
on se souvient qu'elle n'avait pas
beaucoup aimé quand nikos avait lu son
prompteur de travers mais si y'a qu'à
nakamura
suite à cette petite sortie de route la
chanteuse n'avait pas hésité à brocarder
notre grec préféré pendant deux trois
heures on est quand son prénom
tu penses que ça fait bizarre
ceux qui ne craignent pas
des zones est en fait cette semaine
rebelote avec l'acteur vincent cassel
qui a confié sur le plateau de mouloud
achour sur canal+ avoir eu un peu de mal
à prononcer le nom de l'artiste au début
le tout devant anja nakamura bon ben n'a
pas choisi un ensemble
y'a pas à dire il a des cojones le
vincent oui oui c'est bien à toi vince
allez on passe maintenant à lady gaga ou
plutôt lady gaga lady gaga la reine du
costume est devenu depuis quelques
années la reine de la cascade
une fois encore la diva a fini sur le
popotin mais cette fois ci c'est à cause
d'un fan qu'elle avait décidé de faire
monter sur scène lors d'un concert à
vegas
et une fois n'est pas coutume il n'y a
pas que le fan qui était sur les fesses
suite à cette rencontre une chute
douloureuse qui a conduit la star a
réalisé des radios de l'ensemble de son
corps sur instagram elle a tenu à
expliquer qu'elle avait mal partout mais
que tout allait bien des douleurs
partout et même au coeur et cette fois
ci ce n'est pas à cause de son fan mais
à cause de la rupture avec son petit ami
d'un horton une rupture qu'elle a
annoncé à demi mot à ses fans sur
instagram en rédigeant un commentaire
sous une photo d'une copine à elle
durant son enterrement de vie de jeune
fille une femme sur le point de se
marier et moi une femme célibataire
on passe maintenant à céline dion qui
depuis la fin de sa résidence à vegas
inquiète en raison de sa perte de poids
autre inquiétude sa voix ses lignes
semblent avoir du mal à la protéger et à
lui a fait de multiples faux bond ces
derniers temps
[Musique]
suite à de nombreuses rumeurs sur l'état
de santé de céline son médecin a décidé
de prendre la parole
oneapp datar un médecin et ami qui dans
tpm paix s'est voulu rassurant elle
n'arrête pas de faire le tour du monde
et un moment donné effectivement elle a
attrapé un virus tout simplement comme
tout le monde
avant de conclure non seulement ça va
revenir mais je pense qu'elle va encore
nous étonner
nous voilà rassurés on passe à david l
idée qui n'est pas content du tout cette
semaine le fils du taulier s'est
retrouvé malgré lui en couverture du
magazine paris match
un choix éditorial qu'il aurait aimé
validé avant parution il juge que ces
propos n'ont pas été respectées le
magazine n'a pourtant pas respecté sa
parole et mes craintes se sont hélas
avérées justifiées couverture non
consentie titre sous titre montage de
l'interview ne reflète pas fidèlement
qui je suis et ce que j'ai souhaité
exprimer
ne vous y trompez pas décidément entre
la presse et ses relations compliquées
avec laeticia david doit se sentir trahi
de toutes parts espérons qu'il ne soit
pas trop rancunier allez on termine ce
tour des people avec magalie vaé chez
qui elle mais si souvenez vous la star
ac' magalie vaé la grande gagnante de la
star academy saison 5 a eu beaucoup de
mal à poursuivre sa carrière après sa
victoire
elle raconte aujourd'hui cette période
compliquée et évoque l'abandon de ses
anciens amis des amis visiblement
présent pour de mauvaises raisons à 18
ans je n'avais pas la valeur de l'argent
je ne me suis jamais retrouvé à la rue
j'ai fait plaisir à des amis qui ne sont
plus là aujourd'hui quand on paie pour
tout le monde c'est forcément la fête
la production de l'émission lui aurait à
l'époque reprocher de ne pas faire rêver
les gens et lui aurait même suggéré de
suivre une cure d'amaigrissement
j'avais l'impression que c'était ma
faute j'ai été blessé j'ai pensé à
arrêter la musique
si aujourd'hui magalie vaé a décidé de
prendre du recul elle profite de sa vie
de famille et a monté une société
d'événementiel avec laquelle elle assure
l'animation de petits concerts lors de
mariages ou de soirées privées et voilà
l'essentiel de l'actu people c'est
terminé vous allez enfin pouvoir briller
en société tout ça manque
non pardon dont l'express on à gallica
et tout à l'heure vous allez voir c'est
assez fascinant
voilà quand on va tout en haut on peut
aller tout en bas aussi ça peut être
très difficile on parle d'ailleurs la
camorra qui fait encore parler d'elle
est très susceptible cette jeune fille
on sait que nikos avait écorché son nom
elle avait très mal pris c'était aux nrj
music awards le petit dico s'est excusé
elle a refusé d excuse l ai dit qu'elle
n'irait plus jamais aux nrj music awards
entre parenthèses elle y retourne cette
année en tutelle soit des prises à tout
le monde également moi j'ai dit un petit
mot sur el materai des petits cons et là
ce qui est amusant c'est que c'est
vincent cassel dans une émission qui lui
a dit écoute moi j'écoute depuis le
début j'ai toujours galéré à cause de
ton nom je disais qu'un amour as tu vois
en bref la fée japonais l'important
c'est de la musique là comme c'est
vincent cassel et que c'est un artiste
et qu'elle est à côté l'un peu minauder
ou shufu c'est la moins déranger la
presse derrière s'en est pris à elle a
pris ensuite à la poster un tweet en
mettant qu'elle s'en remettait à la
presse qui va encore encore parler de
son nom en parlant d'elle bref ce qui
est assez hallucinant c'est que elle est
très agressif sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment sur son nom je ne sais pas je
suis à raison c'est une fille qui a
beaucoup de talent est ce que vous
comprenez ce on va dire c'est ce ce
cette attitude vraiment de deux divas
alors que cette jeune fille a beaucoup
de talent mental existe depuis un an
chez m passé de marge dans la presse
people
myriam sks calme ardeur dans la presse
people non parce que papa pas plus que
ça c'est pas pour moi c'est pas une
grande star qu'on a envie de mettre en
couvre je suis désolée pour elle encore
et en plus de ça c'est face à ok là de
la musique qu'on aime on n'aime pas
personnellement je déteste mais à des
taux non non non mais c'est vraiment en
plus pour le coup c'est quelqu'un qui
est vraiment très mauvais caractère nous
en coulisses on sait elle refuse toutes
les interviews elle se prend pour je ne
sais pas quoi
pas fou qu'elle redescende vite fait six
mois que dans sa maison de disques aux
mafiosi on a dit aussi il a beaucoup de
talent mais n'est pas facile guillaume
est ce que tu tues non moi je constate
que oui quand c'est petit ça crie fort
et puis après elle va elle va elle va
commander la belle s est pas une et
marine immostar en valeur même si sa
musique sa marge dans le monde entier
oui elle va redescendre avec le temps
c'est normal c'est son caractère elle
est sans filtre moi je me souviens c'est
nico pétomane je refuse
dans l'ordre la baisse avait parlé
sébastien effectivement nous enfin moi
je l'appliquerais pas parce que je sais
que personne personne n'achètera
pourquoi parce que c'est pas une grosse
tare c'est un marché de niche les gens
au dessus de 16 17 ans la connaissent
pas si vous allez si vous avez dans une
ville en province et que vous demandez
qui aie aie aie nakamura je peux
demander à des personnes y en a neuf qui
vont pas la connaître donc soirée n'est
guère à lui un nom compliqué et c'est
quand même devenu une star énorme ne
s'est jamais plaint de sage presse que l
voilà les maîtres du racisme cantonné
corsa noah non moi si on dit deux
corbeaux demain je vais pas dire c'est
homophobe c'est très agaçant ce côté
aujourd'hui ça devient pénible de m 2 du
racisme partout oui donc là en fait
elles sont à peu près à la presse en
disant que la presse en rajouter mais a
trouvé oreillettes et amis mais il ya
trois semaines alors on a joué sur sur
instagram en story elle a écrit cette
année je suis nominé aux nma dans deux
catégories nikos aliagas comment vas tu
m'appeler cette année donc en fait elle
en joue aussi les après-ski rigolo une
petite anecdote personnelle la semaine
dernière je vais au karaoke que mes
copines et là on se dit bon repas chanté
pou qui vous qui vous qui vaut bref
et là le mec du chaos qui nous dit adan
mejias nakamura refuse qu'on mette ses
chansons au karaoké c'est la seule
artiste on parle on parle quand même
d'un petit melon que même nom merci
beaucoup non on parle quand même d'un
petit même les gagnerait tellement être
gentil est simple quand tu as du talent
c'est quand même fou maintenant vous
trompez elle y gagnerait rien du tout au
contraire elle est très intelligente
elle a compris qu'en inventant un
personnage comme ça on allait parler
d'elle et lui pendant très longtemps des
gens qui était très gentil avec tout le
monde et au final quand vous êtes trop
gentil avec tout le monde dans ce métier
on pense plus à vous alors on va vers
une grosse joke la conclusion de mathieu
s'est comporté toi comme un connard et
tu marcheras qui sera une star on peut
voir que dans un standard est ce qu'on
va toujours dans un instant les amis en
parlent encore de plein plein de choses
lady gaga sait millions
et tous les dossiers qui a traité je
disais qu effectivement ce qui est
dommage cette fille qui a autant de
talent qui est une très mauvaise
réputation et là on est en train de dire
si vous nous rejoignez que bien vincent
cassel à parler d'elle en disant oui
c'est vrai au début je t'appelais cannes
amour à moi aussi je me trompe et non du
coup non-stop people en a fait un
article
et elle a encore tweet est quelque chose
d'assez agressif pourquoi est ce qu elle
à ce point agressif pourquoi ce qu'elle
a refusé les excuses de nikos pourquoi
ce qu'elle m'a traité de petit con ont
raison pourquoi bien à un moment et où
effectivement tu n'es dit tout à l'heure
plus on est petit plus on fait chier
comme les grands alors elle a raison
quand elle est admirée par une sur une
émission par un animateur qui n'est pas
fichu d'apprendre son nom par coeur il
ya de quoi s'énerver et puis
deuxièmement si avec des gens agréables
et bien élevé qui faisait carrière sans
soins chez vous même vous ne seriez pas
là maintenant
je prends juste je reprends lutte la
phrase de gérard louvin et franchement
il y connaît dit il faut dix ans pour
faire une carrière et oui c'est vrai et
elle va la faire parce qu'à des du
talent là la première fois qu'elle va
aux nrj music awards pardon moi même
j'avais entendu le son je ne savais pas
qui c'était à quoi elle ressemblait
c'était patience patience mais il y en a
ras le bol de lait vaudois votre mère
vous avez pas fait en un jour patience
les carrières se libère dans l'ue mais
ce personnage implacable quel thé créer
un peu comme ça un peu garce un petit
vin un peu dans le power ce qui fait que
c'est vrai que tout le monde dort pas
exactement maintenant connais son nom et
de son prénom et même ceux qui n'ont pas
écouté
vous connaissez par coeur vous dit vous
aimez pas ces personnalités mais elle
s'en fout vous écoutez ou du fait des
royalties et tout va bien mais qu'elles
interdisent par exemple ses chansons
dans les karaokés pour les jeunes filles
qui veulent s'amuser chanter bel arrêt à
music of partage alors mais avec des
jeunes qui sont là je l aime pas les
gens les gens non seulement les aime pas
mais quand il ya des jeunes des idées
des gens qui l'attendent à la fin de ses
concerts pour faire des autographes
madame continue à jouer les divers
signes payet auteur ap la plus la
plupart des grandes stars le font quand
même nom mais il fait pas avant d'avoir
le melon et pourraient attendre d'être
une star c'est tout en bas côté tout est
dit mais non mais c'est vrai parce que
vraiment moi je le redis elle chante
bien sûr scène allen présence mais
pourquoi je veux comme ça la mafia six
mois tu étais personnes les gens
attendent devant parfois on fait 4
heures quatre heures de route pour avoir
linselles fille d'honneur si elle
n'était pas comme ça on n'en parlerait
pas pendant un quart d'heure que mon
avis mais alors toi ton truc c'est faute
à kona pour qu'on parle de toi
[Rires]
très bien dans ces cas-là donnons la
parole à l'ats galibert d'allonger la
vie
tu veux dire il ya des gens qui me
soutiennent contrairement à toi merci
difficultés à tenir le vide
c'est un message d'adieu cui à ta
douleur je sais ce que c'est et je
t'invite à prendre ma place
une fois au moins avec matthieu
delormeau en tant que chroniqueuse c'est
pas le nom qui va écorché c'est tout à
tête et tout ton temps on va passer à
réfugiés moi qui avais bien cette
émission est de discuter encore une fois
je dis c'est une grande artiste et
j'adore l'écouter je les écoute en
voiture mais ça m'agace juste quand
j'écoute de la musique j'aimerais juste
peut dire qu'en plus la fille derrière
et sympathique et qu'elle kiffe ce qui
lui arrive parce que c'est génial direct
grandira c'est tellement dommage de voir
la grosse vous vous l'a voulu taper
dessus
et puis après vous dire des gentillesses
que vous avez peur qu'elle vous défense
surtout non moi j'ai pas tard qu'elle
sache et mon chou pas comme ça vous
serez pour toujours j'ai 45 ans j'ai
peur de personne exactement les deux
pays on enchaîne les amis avec céline
dion céline dion voilà vous savez que
céline dion elle avait commencé sa
tournée au canada ensuite ça l'a fait
quatre dates à ottawa alors qu'elle
avait dit que elle voulait annuler des
dates parce qu'elle avait des problèmes
de gorge
elle a quand même fait ces dates à
ottawa mais pas celle extrait la semaine
dernière ça a été un massacre on aurait
dit whitney houston en fin de carrière
elle n'arrivait pas à monter au coin
qu'on s'est posé la question est-ce
qu'elle va pouvoir ce qui n'a pas un
problème un problème de gorge est ce
qu'elle est pas trop âgées à ce qu'elle
pourra faire tout ce qui est tout de
suite de leur bosse est dans la nuance
toujours genre abitbol son médecin
phoniatre est venu dans tpm p
pour pour nous rassurer pour le dire
quand elle a vu un virus voilà et que ça
va ça va beaucoup mieux et que la voix
va beaucoup mieux et bien il n'a pas dit
de betty juin bitbol puisque cette
semaine a commencé sa tournée américaine
et alors elle chante très très bien et
elle veut tellement vous montrer en un
extrait exclusif que la voie est revenue
elle chante des chansons que tu es pas
prévu ce genre avec andrea bocelli elle
prend le micro elle dit vous allez voir
c'est la même tessiture et je chante à
fond et regardez ce que ça donne c'est
une exclu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais la question qu'on s'est posée la
faire une tournée mondiale a quand même
un certain âge la voix ça s'abîme c'est
un muscle comme le sexe et du coup on
s'est posé la question et on vous l'a
posée faut-il s'inquiéter pour céline
dion et pour le reste de la tournée on
aura votre sondage dans un instant et
vous la poser à vous également faut-il
s'inquiéter pour le reste de sa tournée
myriam tu dis oui pourquoi j oui parce
que effectivement depuis plusieurs mois
elle a des gros problèmes de santé
depuis crohn et n'est plus là pour
veiller sur elle elle fait un peu tout
et n'importe quoi
elle souffre vraiment de suractivité
elle ne ménage plus avoir comme
d'habitude
et si elle continue comme ça je suis
patient que tout les toutes les dates de
sa tournée elle réussit elles
réussissent à les faire et effectivement
elle a un vrai problème de santé il faut
savoir que l'amaigrissement aussi poussé
parce qu'elle va pas dire anorexique
parce que voilà mais vont à l'école
extrêmement beck a forcément des
incidences sur sa voile savent
absolument pas eu sur la callas qui
était maigre aussi donc c'est pas une
question d'heures six en afghanistan
après son mariage sur maria carey si ça
joue sur le diaphragme j'ai fait les
recherches très très cher sur le
diaphragme
quand tu es trop masse comme ça
forcément ta voix s'en ressent la mère
et la callas avait perdu 35 kilos alors
alors toi tu dis que non ça ne jouera
pas effectivement sur sur la tournée va
être exceptionnel non je pense que comme
si une grande professionnelle même si
elle s'est un petit peu lâché ces
derniers temps là
maintenant elle est partie elle est sur
des rails la tournée va commencer il ya
beaucoup de dates à faire donc je pense
qu'elle est bien suivie et que la suite
au pas un petit peu quand elle est à
paris oui ça peut arriver
alors elle va l'être parce qu'il faut
savoir que tu auras la tournée
européenne en fait c'est à paris que la
résidence je dis pas dans quel hôtel à
mais il est très connu à paris elle va
toujours aux mêmes
oui elle sera tout le temps à paris elle
dort à paris quand elle fait une date en
allemagne et reviennent dormir à paris
une date à londres à leur vient dormir à
paris donc elle va rester quasiment un
mois à paris avis aux fans
et là tu vas pouvoir te reste plus à
l'est à paris on me dit dans
l'oreillette
elle est à voir à ce titre elle est très
sympa avec nous pourquoi elle fait
partie des gens bas qui accepte notre
présence quand même des photos qui
émaillent ha de lacs la mort je suis
côté 2nd nature alterman elle est en
danger elle est en danger parce que
c'est une femme heureuse qui diffament
heureuse dix artistes en perdition
puisque ben oui forcément puisque pour
réussir estivale aujourd'hui il connaît
une carrière tu es heureuse en a pas
voilà un artiste il est malheureux et
puis il est compliqué malheureusement
souvent je pense qu'effectivement il
paraît tellement épanoui dans sa vie
privée qu'on sent qu'il ya une
crispation sur scène je suis moi je suis
pas du tout optimiste sur les images
qu'on a vu parce qu'elle chante en voix
de tête histoire que la voix de tête est
la seule voix très aiguë qu'on ne peut
pas perdre c'est la voix de tête c'est
pas génial on a phoniatre caissier qu on
apprenait un prof de chant à cannes
voilà alors que tu respires bien avec
levante et bien vous y connaissez rien à
la comparaison avec la glace on va dire
que je ne l'ait pas entendu on va dire
ça et maria callas a perdu effectivement
30 kilos quand elle avait 25 ans à l
était pas à la fin elle était quand même
comme ça même où c'est vrai quand on va
côté le fort comme ça comme une athlète
sur sa voix quand on voit que la semaine
d'avant a déjà perdu sa voix qu'elle a
perdu sa voix plein de fois quand elle
est en résidence à vegas qu'elle était
souvent quand même avec ces histoires de
vie rurale a souvent annuler des dates
là la 114 dates déjà prévues jusqu'en
septembre prochain ce qui fait un rythme
incroyable à tenir quand on sait une
telle performance est évident qu'elles
soient pas toutes ses dates quoi
j'allais une voix elle est la seule à
faire 6 oct avait là c'est un instrument
de musique savoie et donc oui il ya
quelques petits des règlements à
certains moments ça ira très bien
et puis on l'a formé moi j'ai pas envie
qu'elle ait des dérèglements moment je
suis en concert avec m
pas tout à fait elle sera à paris à
partir du 21 mai comme ça vous avez les
infos vous me demandez gemini dans
l'oreillette on a parlé également de
magalie vaé parce que magali bay a été
lâché par tous ses amis on se souvient
c'était la gagnante de la star academy 5
si je ne m'abuse et je ne m'abuse pas
elle a fait une interview dans lequel
elle dit que ses potes de l'astarac
ballon entouré beaucoup que tu allais
besson millions d'euros il était très
proche d'elle c'était la bonne copine
et puis ensuite elle a fait des mauvais
placements et les gens qui sont arrivés
qui le proposaient des choses elle a
perdu tout son argent évidemment tous
les amis sont partis
également très très loin et du coup
ballon l'a filmé pour une émission elle
vit à blois aujourd'hui avec sa fille
dans une maison assez modeste elle est
charmante et vous allez voir de quoi
elle vit l'extrait est assez touchant
parce que cette fille nous a beaucoup
touchés quand on a filmé et vous allez
voir qu'aujourd'hui d'un quotidien qui
est plutôt difficile mais elle s'en sort
regarder est heureuse tarifs sont assez
fille puisque pour un anniversaire
départ entrait tout ça c'est 350 euros
avec une un supplément de 50 euros s'ils
veulent que chante et ses 600 euros pour
un mariage pour l'animation de la soirée
et la soirée dansante ce en supprimant
pour chanter 600 euros un tarif conforme
à ceux de tous les autres animateurs de
mariage bien loin des cages chic auquel
magali aurait pu prétendre à la sortie
de la star academy pour aller convaincre
m on l'a gagné un million d'euros on a
fait 10 millions de téléspectateurs sur
sur sur tf1 il ya derrière une
universelle qui doivent sortir un disque
et aujourd'hui voilà c'est vous faites
des mariages des bars milza et vous vous
resté six heures pour 250 euros et vous
rajouter 50 euros de plus si je chante
quelle violence il est quand même quelle
violence elle expliqué dans le
documentaire aussi que malheureusement
elle disait oui je suis une victime de
la grossophobie way tous les genres y
avait fait qu avait fait star academy
qui chante bien ou qui chante pas bien
parce qu'ils ont tous pas fait des
succès à la paillade callas parce
qu'elle était un peu grosse et elle dit
moi j'ai été victime de grosses gt la
grosse on voulait pas de moi
bien sûr la plus grande chanteuse dans
le monde qui vont en plus c'est adel non
mais là d'accord mais problème de magali
te parle des sortants de star academy ou
store lavette et agressions oui à
l'achat du jet chrono à part toi
personne connaît ginette reno est
lassante en est là elle est allée à
montréal qui connaît ginette reno
c'est vrai personne en tout cas quand la
finma a touché très touchante elle avec
sa fille et c'est pour vous montrer
quand même que l'on montre souvent les
gens dans la lumière on montre pas ce
qu'ils deviennent après alors est
parfait a parfois évidemment ça devient
très difficile
le père malheureuse c'est ce qu'elle
nous dit aussi a dit voilà je me
débrouille aujourd'hui aller avec sa
fille d'ailleurs tout à l'heure vous
parlera des reconversions de stars et
vous verrez également que parfois c'est
très très difficile est d'autant plus
difficile que quand on a été connue bah
c'est compliqué d'avoir un métier normal
derrière lui mais kuyt et les autres
gagnants après elle parce que c'est la
dernière reconnaît magali vaé après eux
quatre préludes devenu prof d'anglais
michael sur le renne bourbon qu'on ne
connais pas du tout mais je veux pas son
nom quentin mosimann qui fait vaguement
dj a été la dernière à être un peu
connue parce que c'est pas faux à suivre
mais au delà de la star ac après mâcon
les nôtres a rapidement donc ce
uniquement second quelque chose à dire
donc ma gueule et tu peux te taire on va
parler de david hallyday qui a poussé un
coup de gueule contre la une de paris
match pourquoi parce que le magazine a
mis en une
selon lui sans son consentement il dit
pendant 2
angers systématiquement refusé les
sollicitations de paris match il ya
quelques jours j'ai fini par accorder
une interview la rédaction mon accord
paris match a obtenu sous réserve que je
valide le texte et photos à paraître le
magazine n'a pas respecté sa parole donc
selon lui
eh bien ils ont passé des textes et même
des choses qu'il n'a pas dit et des
photos qui n'a pas validé est-ce que
vous en a parlé tout à l'heure dans la
loge est ce que ça c'est vrai ce que ça
arrive ça peut arriver moi c'est ça
m'est arrivé avec mazarine pingeot
quelques mois après qu'on ait révélé son
existence j'ai fini par la convaincre de
faire un rendez vous photo et une
interview donc elle a refusé les
interviews mais accepter les photos elle
savait très bien que j'étais là pour
paris match donc voilà la semaine après
ses sorties
une photo en couverture mazarine pause
pour match et là elle a fait un scandale
en disant non je n'ai pas posé pour
match pourquoi ce titre est tout à
l'opposé peuvent être blessés par le
titre par la façon dont ils sont mis en
avant par le magazine qu'il quand on
demande relecture catherine canton de
vendre lecture on a relecture plus
interview non à qui se répand sans est
oubliée données relecture agences au
mont royal ce qu'il dit il n'a pas pu
relire le papier en tout cas il dit il y
six ans d'après les informations que
j'ai deux matches et deux du camp david
c'est que le texte voté romy n'a pas été
conforme à ce qui a été publié et il
dément avoir dit je reprends le flambeau
et par ailleurs l'interview elle ait
lieu le samedi 19 dans un restaurant
parisien match boucle mardi matin ils
ont fait des pieds et des mains pour
obtenir les photos la relecture on leur
a donné aux damnés moment il n'a pas la
taille ou tel qu'il avait donnée s'est
assignée par dont il assignerait andré
contrôle interview pendant que pour
payer râle parce qu'il dit rien dedans
il parle de sa musique que je vois pas
pourquoi je reprends le flambeau pour
tous les procès qui en ce moment c'est
une phrase importante quand même posé
fini justement ai dit je reprends le
flambeau à la fin d'une fille rajaona ya
de très bonnes critiques
on n'a pas dit mais là il n'a pas dit
non mais moi je trouve ça quand même
assez honteux que à chaque fois que les
stars demande une relecture moi je la
refuse systématiquement parce que c'est
du panneau est souvent les attaques dont
ils ont été montés trop vite et on
partage des choses et les attachés de
presse il arrive mais pour david et il
ya toutes et à tous tes ordres
précédemment vie normale et de valider
il est touchant sont pas tous ensemble
et attend il de dire que tout le temps
le journaliste a inventé le faventia moi
j'aurai des zorra une anecdote pour toi
mais d'abord oui rachète ça c'est à lui
de vivre pour éviter ces quiproquos où
c'est où ces phrases d'accroché comme ça
qui te permettent
mais ces pratiques pourraient vous
tiendrez vous parfois vous dit des
conneries mejia bon je vais te donner un
exemple en mairie avant le mariage
les quelques faux j'ai fait des
interviews cas malheureusement
n'intéresse personne et qu'on m'a dit ah
relecture ne te fais pas si petit tu
n'es pas si grand et bien effectivement
on m'a donné le papier et quand j'ai
relu j'ai renvoyé et on m'a dit non ça
le rédac chef tient vraiment à cette
phrase non celle là il veut pas lent
révélation celle là il avait vraiment
tout donc c'est par lecture je lui dise
que je veux pas et après il choisit
c'est pour ça qu'il faut éviter la
relique nains et voilà les vautours
allez pas vous avez dû faire des
interviews ça avec nrj12 et pour le pot
du tout du dos se suffit toi là-bas
était publique n'est pas non plus le
monde j'ai jamais dit ça mais pour le
coup le service de presse de nrj12
hissant sur la moindre connerie donc
foire et mais là il y aura un juge de
paix l'interview a été enregistrée ils
vont produire les sons et on verra s'il
a dit ou pas et qui arrive justement à
d'animaux de chacun la wii a très mal
entouré parce que moi quand j'ai les
oreilles est très belle mais non on
retourne à des demandes et on sait très
bien que la re lecture on demande une
confirmation écrite ça que quand on a 15
ans des parts égales ça ne vaut rien
mais on a gagné
les vaio fatigant même score tout de
même terminé avec des artistes qu'on
habille la donne une interview il sait
quand
quand nabila oui quand on me demande une
interview de ma vie la demande une
relecture moi je demande une
confirmation écrite des de faire un
écrit c'est que de toute manière ils
vont changer quelque chose donc on la
fait pas à pas grande c'est pas de la
propagande qu'on fait si un journaliste
interviewe quelqu'un c'est une histoire
de confiance voilà c'est prêt mais
grande terre de ses parents doté avec
lui oui a pas de soucis vous pouvez
revenir et tu vois je peux même te le
signer sur un même souci mais moi je ne
change pas de mains on a le droit
relecture survie du tigre lit mieux je
songe pas et devrait rendre les chacals
celle du fait des travaux dans un
appartement ça vous plaît ne rouge non
bah vous avez le droit que ça vous
plaise pas mais je le change et ça peut
être l'interprétation du journaliste